Jennifer Lawrence Kevin Hart and the
stars who've lost their minds at
Superbowl 52 plus Timothy sha'lame on
meeting Tiffany Haddish and mary j blige
on celebrating her Oscar nominations
with jay-z and Beyonce it's the day
after the Superbowl how's everybody
holding up that game was pretty epic to
watch
Justin's halftime show was fine but my
chicken wings were on fire I cooked and
I was impressed myself okay but listen
the stars turned all the way up
celebrating the Philadelphia Eagles win
over Tom Brady's New England Patriots
including Jennifer Lawrence but wasn't
even on the ground folks she took over
the loudspeaker during her flight on
Super Bowl Sunday
[Music]
it's February 4th and Super Bowl Sunday
we all know what that means
can I please just get
fly Eagle fly by Eagle 5x5 y'all notice
that first class was not having it
alright Jayla of course started with
Bradley Cooper in the movie silver
linings playbook and Bradley did just
play a die-hard Eagles fan he's won in
real life he was at the game but no one
and I mean no one had as much fun than
the Eagles number one fan Kevin Hart and
here's the proof photo you just I'm not
always the bg-30 here yeah that's Kevin
with our Kevin Frazier just moments
before he tried to bum rush the stage
during the trophy ceremony now it didn't
exactly work out for him though a
security guard shut that down real quick
blame it on the a-a-alcohol me trying to
go on stage with the trophy definitely
in the top two stupidest things I've
ever done but who cares the Eagles won a
Super Bowl
yeah I'm still a little tipsy but the
world can kiss my ass you know it didn't
stop there oh no it did not because Jeff
did find his way onto the NFL Network
set we're very lucky to have this guy a
part of this team
happy drinking up I'm on cloud nine
celebrate it's all the kids out there
just want to say don't drink I'm sorry I
love his size with him I love that all
right Kevin's crew included Tiffany
Haddish but she had her eye on a
different kind of prize what does it
mean to be up here and how crazy is
Kevin in this crew now at the Eagles
alone so it's crazy
okay yeah we having a great time we
turning up I'm bout to go down to the
floor with Kevin line to see if I can
meet Mia a fleet that could potentially
be the next father of any babies that I
may have or will I don't even up on my
hi babies but we call Marc Ronnie no
word yet if she found that man but a
young man Tiffany got to meet recently
is call me by your name start Timothy
sha'lame now the two had some pretty
graphic scenes involving fruits this
past year which was not lost on either
of them as I found out when I caught up
with Timmy at the Santa Barbara
International Film Festival Tiffany
Haddish I know you just met she recently
said you guys got to meet and talk about
the fact that you both had sex teens
with fruits I mean what was it like
meeting her listen we are of the fruit
collective and we're some of the few
people that have had fruit / pseudo
sexual scenes on you know on screen this
year so pretty sexual when it went in on
our meter and we're we we both have to
make a movie with Paul Thomas Anderson
that's the goal now because he wants to
work with her and I want to work with
him so I'm on the back end of this love
triangle but that's good
make it happen man make it happen cause
now you guys know I've been following
that kid around all awards season same
with mary j blige my girl she also
received a virtuoso award at the Santa
Barbara Film Festival and she's got
plenty to celebrate and has some really
famous friends cheering her on along the
way so double Oscar nominee I mean has
that sunk in yet how's it feel I mean
it's it's all sinking in every single
day because it's such a beautiful thing
it feels oh man I can't tell you how
good it feels
I love that talk to me about the party
did he through for you guys after the
nomination did you know Beyonce and J
and everyone would come through like
that yeah I knew all my peers and
friends would come through
Puppis my family and he put it together
and I you know I I'm gave him a list and
I said hopefully they'll come and they
all came so yeah that was beautiful and
it was so nice to see everyone again
so you're performing I'm assuming the
the song from the movie no pressure
right now only are you a nominee but now
you got a performer for there um I want
to talk about Justin Timberlake Super
Bowl because people might forget you did
the halftime show with Justin and
ringing and Brent yeah what do you
remember about that performance it's
pretty iconic it was amazing I just
remember having this red spiky hair and
this bright lime green fur on it that
was a rough start at year was sometime
probably aging myself here but that
Super Bowl halftime was one to remember
Justin you messed up not bringing out
NSYNC last night I'm just saying all
right guys we have so much to cover
today but yes Kylie Jenner did have her
baby and no I don't have time to talk
about it so you have to come back
tomorrow and we'll break it all down
everything we know about Kylie and
Travis Scott's a baby girl I'll see you
guys then